-House Democrats unveiled
the text
of their impeachment resolution
today
and called for the removal
of President Trump
through the 25th Amendment.
Meanwhile, the Republicans who
incited a violent insurrection
to overthrow the government
responded by telling everyone
it was time to move on.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The sitting president
of the United States
is the leader of a violent
insurrectionist movement
who incited a seditious mob
of right-wing terrorists
to ransack the Capitol and
overthrow American democracy.
And every day
that he remains in office,
he's a threat to continue
inciting violence
and breaking the law,
including possibly pardoning
himself and others.
Impeachment and removal
are the bare minimum
we should expect
from our selected leaders.
And today House Democrats
began that process,
only to be blocked
by Republicans.
-Today, House Democrats
tried to pass a resolution
by unanimous consent,
calling for
Vice President Mike Pence
to invoke the 25th Amendment.
Republicans objected,
so it failed.
In response, Democrats
have now introduced
one article of impeachment
against the president
for inciting insurrection.
A vote could come
as soon as Wednesday.
-A source close to
Vice President Pence tells CNN
that he has not ruled out
potentially invoking
the 25th Amendment,
but there is some concern
on his team
about what President Trump
could do,
perhaps even worse, should
they start moving on this.
-I'm sorry, you're afraid
of what else Trump could do?
He already incited a violent mob
to attack the U.S. Capitol.
If that's not cause for removal,
what is?
Are you gonna wait
until he shows up
in the fur Viking hat,
so we can all
listen to Ted Cruz
pretend to condemn it?
[ As Cruz ] The President and I
often don't see eye-to-eye
when it comes
to sartorial choice,
but it's just a Viking hat.
He's not carrying
a Confederate flag.
And I notice now on the TV
in my office
that he does have
a Confederate flag.
But it's not like he's
waving it around proudly.
Oh, well, there he goes
with the waving.
You rarely see him do anything
with that much gusto."
[ Normal voice ] Also, why are
we waiting for Pence to act?
He spent four years
by this president's side
as he's repeatedly
excused or incited violence
and sowed the destruction
of our democracy.
I feel like we're a group of
schoolchildren at the zoo,
waiting for the sloth
to do something.
He's not gonna do anything.
Let's go see the polar bear!
Why are we giving him 24 hours?
There's nothing
in the Constitution
that says, before
you impeach the president,
you have to give him
a 24-hour head start.
This isn't hide-and-seek,
although if it was,
I'm betting it would be
pretty easy to find Trump.
He would definitely hide
in a hamper
and then yell, [As Trump]
"Don't look in the hamper.
You should try the basement.
Many people are saying it."
[ Normal voice ] In fact,
the last time
Congress impeached a deranged
white supremacist
who incited violence against
his political enemies,
Andrew Johnson,
they actually did it
before they wrote up formal
articles of impeachment.
There's nothing
in the Constitution
that says you can't do it again.
I'm pretty sure you could
hold a vote on a bar napkin
that says,
"Get the [Bleep] out."
There's no reason to wait
for Mike Pence to do anything.
In fact, Chuck Schumer
and Nancy Pelosi
tried calling him last week
to beg him to remove Trump
through the 25th Amendment,
and he wouldn't even
come to the phone.
-Speaker Pelosi and I
tried to call the vice president
this morning
to tell him to do this.
They kept us on hold
for 25 minutes
and then said the vice president
wouldn't come on the phone.
-We were kept on the line
for 20 minutes.
"He's going to be here
in a minute, a minute, minute."
Well, he never did.
-They kept you on hold
for 20 minutes?
-At least.
-The speaker of the House and
incoming Senate majority leader
called the vice president
to beg him
to immediately remove
from office
the president, who's an urgent
threat to national security.
And he put them on hold
like they were calling
Verizon customer service.
Can you imagine that call?
-In a few words, tell us
what you're calling about.
-Yeah, the 25th Amendment?
-I heard, "Upgrade my Internet."
Is that correct?
-No, I said,
"The 25th Amendment."
-I heard, "Add
the platinum movie package
with STARZ and Cinemax on Demand
for $9.99 a month."
Is that correct?
-No.
I'm calling about removing
a president
who incited a violent
insurrection from office.
-I heard, "Stream episodes of
'The Office' on Peacock."
Is that correct?
-No, and I don't appreciate
the unauthorized
in-house advertising!
I have Premium Plus --
all the content,
none of the ads.
[ Laughter ]
This is an urgent matter
of national security.
And the bare minimum
for the preservation
of our crumbling democracy.
Today the FBI warned
of more possible violence
across the country,
and the National Park Service
closed the Washington Monument
for two weeks,
due to credible threats
to disrupt
Joe Biden's inauguration.
And yet, today, Republicans
blocked the Democrats'
resolution calling for
the removal of Trump,
and for the most part, have
come out against impeachment.
And with only a few exceptions,
the Republican Party
is nearly unanimous
in its belief
that even in the aftermath
of a deadly insurrection
incited by the president,
and with more threats
on the horizon,
we should all just move on
and let the man who incited
a terrorist attack
on the U.S. Capitol
walk away consequence-free.
-House Republican leader
Kevin McCarthy
today said, impeaching
the president
with just 12 days
left in his term
will only divide
our country more.
-You have
Senator Lindsey Graham,
who, on the other foot,
is against impeachment.
He says that's going to do
more harm than good.
-My personal view is
that the president
touched the hot stove
on Wednesday,
and is unlikely to
touch it again.
-Roy, allow me to be blunt.
You're a moron.
Donald Trump
doesn't learn lessons.
He famously paid someone else
to learn lessons
so he could get into college.
And no one loves
touching hot stoves
more than Donald Trump.
He touches them
with his entire face.
I can't believe --
And yet, of course,
I can believe that these ghouls
are hanging on to
the "he learned his lesson"
myth.
Susan Collins
said the same thing
during the last impeachment and
famously that worked out great.
Forget learning his lessons.
This guy needs to be
tried for sedition and jailed,
and strapped to a gurney
like Steve Buscemi in "Con Air."
And we're not just learning
about future threats.
With every day that passes,
we're also learning about just
how violent and menacing
and deadly and heinous
the riot really was
and how much worse
it could have been.
A Capitol police officer
told BuzzFeed,
"That was a heavily trained
group of militia terrorists
that attacked us."
And all the while,
the president was watching it,
encouraging it, and enjoying it,
to multiple accounts.
And so if you're a public figure
in any capacity,
but especially someone
who is complicit
in building or encouraging
this violent
insurrectionist movement
that nearly toppled
the United States government,
the most important thing for you
to be focused on right now,
obviously -- obviously --
is how many followers
do you have on Twitter.
-For conservatives, there's
suddenly a lot of complaints
that they are losing --
abruptly losing --
a dramatic amount of followers.
For example, Tom Fitton
of Judicial Watch
says he's lost 22,000 followers.
Our colleague at Fox,
Brian Kilmeade,
lost 30,000 followers
in four hours.
-Other high-profile Republicans
are upset
they're losing followers online
after Twitter cracked down
on accounts that spread QAnon
conspiracy theories.
-Friday or Thursday I was at a
million followers on Twitter.
I had one million followers
on Twitter
just a couple days ago,
and now I'm down to 922,000.
-I lost, over the weekend,
55,000 Twitter followers.
-Oh, my God!
You lost followers on Twitter?
Someone call 911!
Scratch that!
Call 9111
for special emergencies!
AKA 911 Premium Plus.
I know I ask this a lot,
but, uh, what the [Bleep]
is wrong with you people?
A violent mob of seditionists
storm the Capitol
and attempt
to overthrow democracy,
people died,
and you're whining
about losing
followers on Twitter?
"They also took away all my
Gold Bars on Candy Crush.
You know how hard it is
to beat the Jelly Queen
and Cupcake Carl?
Thanks a lot big tech."
If a mob of violent terrorists
lays siege to the Capitol
and threatens to return,
and your biggest concern is
the number of Twitter followers
you lost,
you're a sociopath.
And that's not just me
saying that.
I'm pretty sure
that's in the DSM.
Who monitors
their Twitter follower account
that closely, anyway?
The only thing more sociopathic
that complaining
about lost Twitter followers
is bragging about
gained Twitter followers.
"Pretty good week.
I added about 20.
I had some
pretty sweet cat content."
Also -- and this is just a tip
for the future --
if Twitter announces
that they're banning Nazis
and insurrectionists and crazy
conspiracy-theory nut jobs,
maybe don't complain
at the exact same time
that you're losing
Twitter followers?
That doesn't sound
quite as sympathetic
as you think it does.
"Well, well, well,
the police start
rounding up the arsonists,
and suddenly, I lose customers
in my store
Kerosene & Matches R Us."
And if you thought it couldn't
get any more nauseating
and self-serving than that,
you were wrong,
because when they weren't
complaining
about losing followers
on Twitter,
the very same Republicans
who spent months
spreading monstrous lies
about the election,
who fed their rabid base
a steady diet
of unhinged conspiracy theories
and fantasies
and violent retribution,
who incited
the insurrectionists' riot
that breached the Capitol
for the first time
in 200 years,
had the gall to turn around
and start calling
for unity and healing.
-The White House just released
that statement,
saying impeachment would,
in the White House's words,
only serve to further
divide the country,
and that this is a time
for healing and unity.
-Now it is time for America
to unite, to come together.
-We're at an important point.
I'm very concerned
about where we're at.
I hope -- I hope -- we can
begin to come back together.
-We have a chance here
to start over.
President Trump did
the right thing last night,
in the last 24 hours.
Instead of trying to match
what President Trump has done,
the radical Democrats
are talking about
another impeachment
that will destroy the country
even further.
-We've got to be able
to bring volume down.
Speaker Pelosi talking about,
"Well, let's impeach
the president,"
with one week to go,
and to try to drive this,
is trying
to drive a wedge further,
to make a difficult situation
more difficult.
And right now, we need to
turn the rhetoric down,
not try to turn the volume up.
-And let me begin
by doing my part
to begin the healing process,
bring down the temperature,
and tone down the rhetoric by
saying this.
Wait. First, can I have
calming music, please?
[ Soft music plays ]
Thank you.
[Bleep] you, you cretinous
insurrectionist gargoyles!
Of course, you guys
want to move on!
The kid who [Bleep] himself
at prom
is the one who always wants
to shift the conversation
to everyone's summer plans.
"So, Gary, it happened
during the Macarena?"
"It doesn't matter
when it happened!
Tell me about your internship."
You guys incited a violent mob
that rampaged across the Capitol
trying to overthrow
the government,
and now you want us to
see unity and healing?
I'd call you
craven, soulless ghouls,
but in the case
of these seditionist dip[Bleep],
they're more like
soul-devouring ghouls.
"I love a good
Southern-fried soul
with a side of peach tea
and pecan pie."
How can we find unity
with people who literally
want a confederacy?
But when it came to faux,
self-serving
"Let's lower the temperature"
rhetoric,
the cake was taken by future
former First Lady Melania Trump.
-First Lady Melania Trump
has just released a statement
regarding last week's protests.
She writes, in part,
"I am disappointed and
disheartened
with what happened last week.
I find it shameful
that surrounding
these tragic events
there's been salacious gossip,
unwarranted personal attacks,
and false misleading accusations
on me
from people who are looking
to be relevant
and have an agenda."
-And let me
make something clear!
Whether you're a Republican
or a Democrat,
seditionist or
law-abiding citizen,
you leave this poor woman alone!
And this woman and this one!
Because any one of them
could be her.
And better safe than sorry.
I mean, how dare you?
Salaciously gossip
about this woman
after she "be best" for you!
For you!
She's bester than any of you!
She reher-- She refurbished
and "reherbished."
[ Laughter ]
That's how best she is!
Did them both! Two for one.
Saved your money!
She refurbished the White House
tennis pavilion for you!
[ Laughter ]
Not for her.
You think she has time
to play tennis
between sending messages
via jacket
and hating Christmas
with all of her heart?
At this point,
the only acceptable option,
and the bear minimum for the
preservation of our democracy
is the immediate removal and
prosecution of Donald Trump
for sedition
and the expulsion
of anyone
who aided him in this coup,
including the likes
of Josh Hawley and Ted Cruz,
and Alabama Congressman
Mo Brooks,
who whipped up the mob
into a frenzy
before it stormed the Capitol.
And then, after that, we need
immediate far-reaching
structural reforms
to our democracy.
If you're a right-wing pundit,
maybe try to summon
the same sense of
outrage and urgency
over losing our democracy
that you feel over losing...
-55,000 Twitter follower.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "Donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.